[Music]
it's the middle of September and the
last guardian should have been out next
month it's recently been delayed until
early December however Justin hey walled
recently went down to Sony and had a
chance to play the game which I believe
is the first time that anyone gamespot
has played The Last Guardian it's not
the first time that we played it and
this is the bill that they're showing at
TGS I we got to see it a little bit at
e3 I got a little bit of hands on but
this is the first time when we've been
able to record our game play when were
able to show off how really bad we are
at the game I I felt like I was taking
my first steps in in a new body in a new
world in this game at some times and to
be fair so what what we saw the of the
game this time it wasn't the beginning
this was not the tutorial that was not
an intro to the world it was kind of
throwing you into the middle so there
were some things that you were kind of
expected to already know so as you're as
you watch the footage you see that the
game shows you push this button to push
something to push this button to jump
and I think those are things that you
would be expected to know at that point
how to interact with the monster and how
to just interact in the world and but
for me jumping in right at that point it
was definitely a steep learning curve
but I don't think that's going to be
indicative of the final game so a lot of
the things that I think people are
wondering about are the things they've
been showing for a long time that
includes is Treecko or Trico the sort of
hybrid animal that you are I believe
guarding although I'm curious maybe he's
the guardian of the boy in the end but
how does it know that could make sense
but I'm curious like how was your
interactions with Treecko like how did
it feel like he was a companion did you
did it really feel like you weren't that
familiar with him yet because i know the
devs explained that as you develop you
know as you spend more time with him
you'll be able to able to understand
each other a little bit better like how
did that experience work out so I'm kind
of of two minds around treacle I love
the design of the creature I remember
when I first saw it that I wasn't really
that taken with it but when you see him
from a distance in his those glowing
green cat eyes like it just looks so
cool to see him through shadow and then
you get up close and that mix of fur and
feathers as you climb onto his back and
clamber over him like he's it's a really
cool looking creature and it feels both
kind of cute and menacing and scary at
the same time and you don't really know
to to expect out of it and it felt like
it the portion where I was at in the
game there was not a super close bond
and it maybe that's what they were
trying to get across with with that
section of gameplay so you can call to
call to the creature it's a lot like eco
in that sense where you can call to your
companion and they'll come towards you
and in this case Treecko might come
towards you you can kind of point him
towards things you can direct him he's
not always gonna listen right away
though which is it's both frustrating
because you know you're playing a game
you're solving puzzles that are very
similar to the other games in it in that
series that they've done before so you
kind of want to you know get that puzzle
but like I know how to solve this I'm
sure if I go pull this thing it'll make
the door come open but but at the same
time it does give it that that
personality where it's almost like a
precocious child or or a pet who like a
cab who is not necessarily gonna listen
to you when you say hey cat go over
there and then the cat just like looks
over at the corner and goes now yeah I'm
not gonna do that that never works you
cannot tell a cat what to do and treecko
is is a mix of different kinds of
animals the strongest one and I think
it's mannerisms and the way that it
moves is a cat so it's just like a weird
dog bird looking cat creature it's
somewhat aloof maybe it's a loof in some
ways but and I feel like this is another
thing that just takes a lot of you have
to spend a lot of time in the game to
get the hang of yeah but the way that he
reacts to things around you it is kind
of how you know what to do in the game
so it I don't think you're gonna get as
blatant hint says as I gotta make sure
both things are popping up on screen
saying do this and I had developers
around me who were helping out with like
well if you you would have already
learned that if you grab this item this
is how you you kind of use that if you
watch Treecko though he'll he looks
around at his environment so he'll he
looks up there's one part where he's
looking up at the ceiling and a thing
that you have to light and when you
light that then he jumps up on there
because he's like attracted to the light
he wants to to be closer to that and
then if you ride on his back when he
jumps up there then that gets you to
this higher ledge and you're able to
solve the puzzle that way ok so did
maybe your anticipation or your hype did
you feel like finally picking this
controller up and playing the game like
delivered what you were expecting and if
not maybe
how is this different from Fumito ADA's
past works eco and shadow of the
colossus the years i think of in some
ways diluted what this experience could
have been because coming off of i co /
out of the clauses like just too amazing
experiences that tell you so much about
the world and how to play the game
without ever being very explicit yeah
you are just kind of forced to figure
things out and so it's hard to get a
feel for that if you're not going in
from the very beginning because i think
a lot of the tutorial elements from eco
and shadow the classes in particular are
very subtle so you have those elements
in the last guardian as well where
there's a lot going on in this world and
it's not clear what all of it means and
you kind of want to explore you want to
you want answers to these things and i
don't think you're gonna get answers to
everything but at the same time it also
feels like it borrows maybe a little too
much from front firm for me in
particular a lot from eco because now
you're you're back in a castle and I see
things that are very familiar on it I
don't think it's the same castle but it
also doesn't feel quite as fresh as new
as as something that is unsurprising and
that I didn't know what I was getting
into I've I felt very familiar which
isn't necessarily a negative thing but I
you know after waiting all this time
after having played through Rico and
shout of the Colossus you know I kind of
wanted another experience that's just
going to surprise me so one of the
things that is pretty particular about
who ate as games in the past is the
controls have been somewhat floaty right
they're not it's not this precise thing
you're sort of wrestling with a very
organic feeling character how does that
translate to the Last Guardian
especially from some of the stuff I saw
your walking on pretty precarious land
and structures yet you do have to be
very very careful with the way that you
move your character because they does
make an open walton we've seen that in
the other games were if you're walking
along the ledge if you're not careful
you can just walk off that ledge and it
can either kill you or send you back to
the beginning of a puzzle and that
happened to be a few times but at the
same time after having played so many
games that have such tight controls I'm
a little bit hesitant to be to feel like
this is going to be the finished product
like I hope that the controls
have some more work that's going to be
done to them all right thanks Justin for
all that new info the rest of us will
get a chance to play the game in about
three months time I'm hoping it's worth
the wait what are you hoping let us know
in the comments below do you think the
last garden will live up to its
prolonged development cycle otherwise
stay tuned gamespot com for more
coverage of the Last Guardian as a
release approaches
you